okay well welcome everyone to this
lecture actually I haven't done one of
these lectures in a long time
so today's topic is going to be king
marches and I've um there's actually a
really nice book that yasuko wrote it
was like Paths of Glory or something
like that and
there's a lot of examples of King
marches of different kinds so both on
the winning side and like how the king
gets chased
um gets checkmated so we're going to
take a look at all of the well several
examples of those so I have I think five
examples
so this is I think
um the most well-known position when it
comes to King marches
so white to move
um I think some people should be
familiar with this
and also given the topic
I think
maybe it's um it's a bit of a hint
uh King marches are actually quite I I
don't think I've ever done it in any of
my games at least not in the middle game
and I had one game where I I it was a
complicated game I was like doing well
and I didn't win and then when I was
analyzing later my coach at the time was
like oh you know it makes sense if you
put your King on the other side of the
war before you start attacking your
opponent
uh so when it when it comes to positions
with King marches a lot of it most a lot
of the time it includes having
domination so it's not like you start
marching your king and then all of a
sudden your king just gets checkmated in
the middle of the board
so in this position if we and we will do
this
um in every example we look at when we
look at a position first we will start
by
doing a summary of the position and
what's going on so in this position
white is completely dominating it has
full control of the D file at this F7
Pawn is a huge Target so this Rooks just
cannot move at all and the only reason
Knight G5 is not moving is because of
this battery of the bishop and the Queen
but this pieces also cannot move because
the second this piece is moved and
Knight G5 is coming and it's just game
over so the question is like how to make
progress for white because a move like
G4 doesn't work out there's Queen F3
so at some point even with this kind of
a dominant position white does have to
find a way to win so white star is
bringing the king
so there's a really nice path for the
king to go to H6 when the King goes to
H6 then it's just going to be game over
this King cannot stop because uh Rook F7
so in the game black just kind of gave
up
and maybe didn't realize what king H2
was until it was too late because once
the king gets here
the king just gets to H6 so Bishop want
to see it and
a king H6 is coming and there's nothing
to do
so a really dominant position
so if Bishop C8 King H6 okay it's
checkmate
so what white um sorry what black could
have tried is Bishop C8
and the problem for black in this
position is
because the position is just so bad that
um
white doesn't even need this Rook to win
the game so why it actually can win the
game with a move Knight G5
and just giving up this Rook now that
the bishop so it's uh it's nice to be
flexible right so now that the bishop
has moved away
we have this Knight G5 move
and I think this is something happens
mentally with players when in your mind
you're like okay I cannot move this
piece because of this reason and then it
just stays in your brain regardless of
what happens to the position sometimes
we don't really keep up with the changes
in the position
when we make too many assumptions so
Bishop C8 but okay also Knight G5 is a
very concrete move so you cannot just
play
Knight G5 and not calculate anything
so Knight G5 so if
um let's say giving up this queen
then and it looks like white has run out
of pieces to attack with which sometimes
happens when we're attacking we give up
too many pieces but now white can just
simply play G4
and the idea is if HG then H5 so H6 is a
threat and if takes then
Queen H6 and now mid is Unstoppable so
because of this placement of these ropes
this King isn't just a really bad
position
and if they take Bishop D7 which of
course is more logical
than G4 again
and same idea of
taking on Queen H6
and if takes an H5 again same idea and
the position is just completely lost
so let's move on to other examples so
this other example that I'm going to
show you
is also a really well-known one and
more of a fun game rather than anything
this was a casual game I believe but
this is another well-known
king walk but this time
the king is on the losing side so this
is by Alaska
Knight F3 F5 I'm not going to spend a
lot of time in the opening it's not
the main point of
this lecture
so Bishop goes to G5
takes E4 I remember I used to play this
touch positions as a kid
um
my repertoire from my childhood
it's not the greatest I play the French
and the Dutch and the Stonewall so I
really did Terrible Things to my light
Square Bishop starting from my childhood
but I remember that it was kind of known
that this lines are kind of annoying for
for black because this allowing E4 early
and this structure yeah that's what I
remember from my childhood that this was
not supposed to be good of course modern
engines might have their own opinions so
take Stakes B6
and that goes to E5
The Not So subtle thread the castles
Queen H5 so again another not so subtle
threat of taking on F6
and then
checkmating on H7 so opening the path of
this bishop
so so here
black should take only five but I can
understand why this is a difficult move
to play because
the bishop on F6 looks like a defensive
piece so how can you give up one of the
few Defenders of your king it's a black
plays what looks like a logical move of
Queen E7 with the idea is
takes takes
another queen defense but unfortunately
move orders in chess one of the most
important aspects of calculation that
sometimes if we have an idea and
one more order doesn't work out maybe we
can try changing the move order and but
okay this one is not a simple
calculation
but this is another really well-known
position or a well-known game so in this
position white took on H7
and now Knight F6
so of course skin cannot go back we have
a checkmate
so the King goes forwards but now the
king gets checkmated by force
so G3
um so there is made in two
if um white simply castles then Knight
H2 is just Unstoppable but I think the
game is actually a lot nicer because it
should be two
so the king actually runs all the way to
G1 King D2 and checkmate
um
you know I'm not sure if I've seen I
want to say I've seen both this game
with king detune castle I think Castle
is a better Checkmate yeah it's just
cuter to Castle and check my dear
opponent
okay so this one this game is of course
very old but just a very classical
example of
this King runs so another one is by
Alexandre Larkin so this against
um
Yates so this is another like a very
classical well-known game so so far I
think everything we're looking at
um maybe people are familiar with
but at this one we will play through the
game will actually Focus through some
aspects of the game
so D4 E6 here for Knight F35
so DTX C4 is a very trendy move right
now
so this is a very
trendy opening but hard to imagine this
opening becoming trendy without the help
of engines because it's just such an
ugly way of
playing
oh no sorry not this I mean although
there is also a move so just playing
this is just such a modern way of
playing
but instead Bishop G5 Castle
Rook C1 so we will stop at some key
points
so Bishop goes here
so it gives up the center
94. so F5 yeah so F5 is a bit of a
difficult move to play but
um
we can see maybe some
trouble with this King although
uh when you play a move like F5 here um
it's just such a long-term difficult
move to play because there's
um the C8 Bishop might become a problem
so whenever black gives up the center
like this at some point in this position
at some point black has to get in either
C5 or E5 or something to fight against
the center otherwise if uh white black
just allows white to do everything just
Castle go E4 white just gets the world
and um
what is black even doing
but F5 is a bit of a too middle of a
move
so of course this has to be taken
and now B5 and I think this is a very
interesting point in the game
because again if we stop and
this mouse
so if we stop and just think about what
has happened
so all these moves that
Blog has made has left him with two
backwards pawns so C6 and E6 Pawns but
the black's idea is very clear right to
play Bishop B7 and then get in C5
quickly so if the bishop goes to D3 can
even win this bishop and immediately
goes C5
Bishop goes here then again Bishop B7
and C5 is Rook C8 C5 is coming so if
flag manages to get this moves in at
least you know kind of justifies what
black is doing
and uh to move that white plate here
white took which um which is a good move
but I think can be difficult to move to
play because sometimes we have a
difficulty giving up our Bishop
but if we look at the position
if you look at the position and the
structure
because there is a light squared bishop
and so many pawns on the light squares
it makes a lot of sense for white to
trade everything and leave black with
this really bad light squared Bishop and
then
ideally if we also okay so this was
taken so if we look at a position
it's a good idea to kind of think about
you know just like long-term thinking of
okay which pieces do I want to trade
which pieces which trait I just want to
completely avoid so if you can't imagine
this two nights coming off the board
then it's it's just really hard to
imagine how this bishop is ever going to
become part of the game with this
structure even if the bishop goes on
some kind of a diagonal it's hard to
imagine what it will be doing there
because it doesn't like if um if I take
this Knight off the board if I can
visualize that and even if this bishop
somehow ends up on e4 it's not really
doing much there not that this bishop
really has a path of going to A4 so I
already picked this position
um
strategically becoming quite difficult
for a plug because of these holes in the
position and of course this fight for
the C file the only open file in the
position
a move like E5 is is just going to leave
too many holes in the position because
black will still have this difficult
it's problematic piece the C8 bishop and
in addition they'll also have this D5
weakness
so in the game castles
A5 is trying to get in something like B5
Basics so Knight B3 A4 and Knight C5
so white is following up with this plan
and
trying you know to exchange this night
and then once these nights are off the
board we can't imagine this night
landing only five and then we get this
very classical example of a good night
versus a bad Bishop where this E5
Knights on the dark Square will just
completely dominate this light squared
Bishop
and uh so in this game actually really
feels like black was kind quite
cooperative and a lot white just to kind
of get the world
but I think it's just a very good
example when we have this kind of
example where one side is just
completely dominant because it just
demonstrates the idea so well
so everything comes off the board
so before and Rook fc1
and another problem in this position for
black is again
the trading of the pieces so of course
so of course for black to
fight for the C file at some point this
bishop has to move and The Rook has to
go to C8 but black has to think about
what will happen if all the pieces come
off the board so if we make a couple
more moves 95 and we already see that
the Rook C8 runs into a lot of problems
because if we
trade everything
simply Knight D3 and at least one Pawn
will fall
and then black is going to have to
defend this difficult end game down upon
and the and the problem is the
issues that black had in the position
don't go away
because after the before plan Falls or
maybe even the Knight goes to C5 and
takes this Pawn instead
because if we take the pawn on A4
instead we're leaving them with the pawn
on the door squares which means the
bishop cannot even defend so this Pawn
might fall immediately
so immediately as soon as black tries to
fight back and tries to fight for the
only open file in the position
and like bad things happen right like
the position just starts to fall apart
so instead
so already we see that there's huge
issues in the position
so it becomes a matter of how wide is
going to try to win this and how wide is
going to
convert a disadvantage so black plays
Rook B8
F3
of course opening Square for the king
and now B3 of course there is no reason
of taking
and opening the file for this Rook
so A3
and again we see this um
this move will run into this problem
and again Knight D3 Knight goes to C5
and at least one Pawn will fall and this
is very unfortunate because after the
Knight goes to C5
hitting both tons let's say you can get
795 now the bishop doesn't have time to
go to square
to defend the pawn but even if it did
the king will
just go and take this Pawn
does it so the structure is really bad
for black
so instead black plays H6
white starts bringing the king
H4 in this kind of structures H4 is a
very useful move
because once the pun goes to H5 it will
really fix the structure which means the
G7 Pawn will just stay on G7 forever
uh this Pawn will just never be able to
move and there's another Target in the
position
and when it comes to conversion top
players like strong players are very
good at this kind of things just
creating more problems for the opponent
so it will goes to f8 and now the king
is joining the game
so attacks the bishop
Bishop A6 and oh
and now Rook 5 to C6
so like also hitting this Pawn
and now King F4 so now the king is
joining the game and uh black
like now at this point because there's
just so many Targets in the position
so many issues I can't really move and
cannot really hope for any kind of
counter play
because this Pawn is hanging this bishop
is hanging so which means now the pieces
are really limited the rule cannot move
the pawn hangs the other cannot hang the
cannot move the bishop hangs so King
goes back
onto H5
so G3 it's a bishop F1 and this is
something I was mentioning before like
even if the bishop gets on a diagonal
it's very unclear what it's doing so
okay like black did manage to develop
their Bishop so the bishop does go did
go to A6 it's on a very long diagonal
but unfortunately it's doing absolutely
nothing
there's nothing important going on in
this diagonal so it's just a very
useless piece
so Pawn to G3 goes back Rook F7 so it's
at some point
um
we have to start making progress here
and Rook G8 so black strategy is
basically is just kind of you know just
sitting there and hoping
to somehow hold this position but of
course the position
um the game is going to end in a few
moves because Knight D7 a really nice
smooth threatening Knight F6 taking the
Rook King goes back
but nonetheless now Knight F6 of course
taking is impossible Rook H7 is made
so instead Row Cafe it was played
but Rook F6 and now King E5
so now the king dominates the rook and
The Rook doesn't really have any squares
to go to the rule goes to f8 very simple
checkmate
so I yeah I really enjoyed this game
it's a very classical game
and uh the things that I like about this
game is just a complete Domination by
white so starting with taking on D5
this position then coming and exchanging
the knights
and then
like taking control of the C file and of
course finally
when the king joins the game and
this final move of playing King E5 I can
get to the final position
nope yeah and then the game ends with
this centralization robot King E5
so let's take a
so let's take a look at our next two
examples so the next two examples are
kind of related to each other
so the next one will be by
why isn't it working
by
uh
actually is kind of one well known as a
former world champion kind of well known
for this kind of King walks
so in this position
so again if we do a summary of the
position of what is going on again we
have this Dynamic of Knight versus
Bishop
and we have this Knight on B3
on the light square and a black Bishop
on D6 on a dark Square
and in the other position we have the
different Dynamic of
um of the White Knight on E5 and the
black Bishop on A6 but the dynamic is
the same
so if we do a summary so there's not
that many pieces left on the board so
unlike the other game we have Queens on
the board
it's a white once again funny enough is
controlling the C file and the problem
for black is this A5 Pawn so this A5
Pawn is just a forever problem because
it's a fixed pawn and this Knight is
just forever attacking it and because of
this Pawn structure
this bishop doesn't really have much of
a future
and uh it's actually very unfortunate
that black has to dedicate a queen and a
rook to defending the pawn but as the
position stands it's it doesn't like
really look that terrible because we
have to think about again like you have
a nice position
like when we do a summary on when we do
an evaluation of the position okay
there's a nice position we have certain
kind of advantages but
um how to take a advantage of them
and well so I don't know if um this
concept of the principle of two
weaknesses is a very familiar one like
if your opponent has one weakness then
they can defend it if they can defend it
then it's possible that
you cannot really make progress anymore
because there's one weakness and your
opponent defends it and that's pretty
much it
and we do know that this kind of passive
defense where you have a bad position
but you're just sitting there and you
know and just kind of fighting back and
trying not to harm your position and
your opponent just cannot make progress
this is a way to defend
but the you know the principle of the
two weaknesses is trying to make another
weakness for your opponent so instead of
just having this one weakness where they
can just dedicate all their forces to
this weakness and just defend the
position all of a sudden they have two
weaknesses and of course defending two
weaknesses is more difficult
especially if the weaknesses are very
far away from each other so in this
position white plays
H form and black response with H5 so if
we look at the plant structure it's very
symmetrical
this Pawn structure it's kind of a funny
one so for plug this makes
um
a lot of sense because black has black
has a dark squared bishop and they have
put all their pawns on light squares
so the bishop at least they're not
locking their Bishop in and like in the
last game where we saw the bishop
was locked in by Black's own ponds but
of course this A5 problem and again in
this position we have to think about
peace exchanges and what happens if all
the pieces come off so if all the
Heavies come off
at least right now if we take all the
pieces off
it's going to become a matter if it's
possible
for black to defend this A5 Pawn which
of course it is with a move like Bishop
C7 and if white will be able to kind of
do some kind of a breakthrough to bring
the king in
so now because
because white has such good control of
the position and
it moves like uh Queen B7
hmm like don't really work out and The
Rook again cannot move
and to something like Bishop Bishop B7
like around allowing this Rook trade is
probably not a good idea because then
uh black will be exchanging um Defender
which means the A5 Pawn will fall so
black kind of has to go back and forth
okay my throat is killing me
so with this H5 Pawn
makes a lot of sense for white to try to
play something like G4
but since the king is there it's a good
idea to bring the king to the other side
so now Rook C2 and this is the kind of
position where there is no reason to
rush for white because
it's not like
um if white doesn't hurry or white takes
their time there's going to be a really
drastic change in the position
because the pawn structure is not going
to change so that's mean the only change
that could happen that would change the
nature of the position
and otherwise like peace exchanges but
that also is not going to happen because
we know that going into an end game is
problematic for black so black is just
kind of shuffling around
and now it's a good now it's time for a
white to bring their King to the other
side of the board
so black is just shuffling
so the queen goes to E2
Queen goes to B7
um now uh
to see one
so we'll just repeat the moves a few
times so F4
and here actually
this G4 move is a huge threat
so playing something like
F5 is too difficult of a move to play
because
um
something like Knight C5 will just make
things very problematic
now you got three of you yeah I mean
this I mean making this kind of move
moves like F5 is just so difficult like
I think even cycle even like if like you
you think F5 is the best moving in a
position psychologically this would be
such a difficult move to play
um so but here black actually has
um to prepare
for this G4 move so I maybe this is a
good time to pause and think about
what to do like G4 is coming let's say
White's next move is going to to bg4 how
can block prepare
so how to defend against G4
F5 F5 is is not it's not what we want
now F5 Knight C5
this position will fall apart
so it's not just stopping G4 it's also
thinking about okay like G4 is coming
so you cannot like physically stop this
Pawn from going to G4
so like how can you prepare for it how
can you face it
so you have to think about like what
does upon going to G4 mean
like why is this G4 move so bad
okay so someone suggested Bishop B7 but
um the thing about Bishop E7
like um
white would really welcome giving up
this Pawn because giving up this Pawn
just means opening the H file so when
your king is lonely
you know opening files on your king is
actually it's just going to be game over
because now The Rook will quickly switch
back
and the position again will fall apart
y86 just a little closer maybe right
so King H6 here
next move I'll go Queen and again like
I'm not even so let's say you go Bishop
E7 here right
um
like I'm not scared of playing a move
like this because if you take then I go
Rook H1
and uh okay you're getting made it so
you have to go H4 but now I can't even
go F5 so now you're just getting
attacked from different sides of the
board
so first let's think about yg4 is such a
scary move
uh if you look at Black's King black
king is just completely lonely so black
skin comes under attack there's just no
one to defend him and of when we're
going when we're playing G4 we're
attacking this pawns that are on light
squares right and bike has a dark Square
Bishop so the star Square Bishop is
actually not going to be very useful in
defending the king
if I like magically put this even if I
put this bishop on G7 somehow
this bishop would not be much of help
because after G4 so whenever I play G4
this exchange is going to happen and
once let's visualize like this exchange
happens like automatic next move is just
going to be H5
why it is just trying to destroy this
Pawn structure just go after this you
know remove H5 from the word exchange
the span and then go H5 and just open
files and start attacking this King
uh so that's a huge problem for black so
black has to think about
so when you're under attack what are
some good ways of
um defending someone is of course
exchanging pieces unfortunately that's
impossible because
like we cannot get rid of this Rooks if
we can just if we could get this Rooks
off the board right for
black at least they're not getting
attacked
um so whenever this G4 HG Queen G4
happens so the H file opens but H file
opening also
can be an opportunity for
um
black to defend
so one way that black can so what black
should have done in this position
so when the age file opens we want to be
able to play root gauge 8 but the
problem is
if we move this Rook right preparing for
this G4 H5 then our Bishop hangs so so
like the way that black species are set
up is just like things are getting in
the way of each other so for example if
the King was already like
somewhere like G7 so if I like pass a
move so actually King G7 is the correct
move but just just to show what I mean
so let's say something like this happens
right so now black is just actually on
time because the Rook goes on h8
stopping H5 black does bring another
Defender to the king side also at the
same time attacking this pawn and that
Rook H1 is not possible because it's
Rook Hank so now all of a sudden Black's
position is becoming okay because
um
now black is getting some counter play
so after King G7 of course black will
white will immediately play G4
takes takes and again a key moment of
how to defend because rogate so again H5
is coming allowing H5 and HG
I hope this part is very clear that
lying this is just
came over it's just uh very terrible at
least at the very least this is just
very bad
so what can we do to if H5 is coming get
some active counter play or just prevent
H5 altogether so black to move what can
black possibly do here
server kj8 is not a move
where else can we do here
ah Rook G8 is not possible because this
bishop is hanging so The d8 Rook just
cannot move and this was one of the
problems from the very beginning when we
set up this position
is black movement for black is just
difficult
it's like difficult to just find moves
that like don't hang pieces which is why
when white was doing this whole thing of
running the king over and like preparing
this
G4 push with F4 coming Bring the queen
back all black was doing was shuffling
back and forth with the King because
other moves were not really possible
so what um so rookie trade is not
possible
yeah Rook A6 is the defensive move in
this position because the king is so
lonely black has to find a way to bring
the defensive resources towards the king
so of course the best one would be the
queen so if we could transport this
queen to F5 this would solve Black's
problems on the king side
and
so if the Rooks are exchanged now
there's really active counter play
because the queen goes to D3 defense G6
and also at the same time now
this E3 Pawn is hanging so the positions
start to get starts to get messy
and if not
let's say
wait
and if the Rook moves back
again preparing H5 now the root goes to
h8
and
if repairing this the row goes to H5 and
now we can offer a trade of pieces
and maybe even something like queen h8
or like Bishop B7 now the bishop maybe
can go to F6 so now again there's some
counter play for black actually quite a
bit of counter play because now there's
Targets in White's position so the
position changes drastically
and the whole uh the reason that this
Rook A6 worked in this position
is because before the queen was on E2 so
this Rook A6 was just never a
possibility but now that the Queens
switch to the other side of the port
narrow k6 and exchanging pieces because
when you attack and you exchange pieces
you're getting rid of your opponent's
attackers and usually your pieces are
the Defenders so that's normally a very
good trade
but instead after Queen E2
um black played Queen B7
but now G4
and H takes G4
and now H5 so black did manage to bring
the queen to the other side of the board
but they did allow this H5 move
and um
it's just not getting to the other side
of the board as efficiently because
another position that we saw the Rooks
came off so in the other position the
queen was already on D3
like super not super used to leeches I
have to find my way around
yeah in this position so in this
position a pair of Rooks comes off and
the queen gets to D3 like again the
queen and the thing is like if H5 check
um I can't like maybe even consider like
taking on E3
and
bringing the Rook from this side like
the position like starts to get messy
and whenever you have a position where
you're suffering and you know your
opponent is
putting pressure on you then message is
normally a good sign
so that means you know at least you have
a chance
but in this if we compare positions that
after Queen B7
H5 uh White still has complete control
of the position of the C file and
um
if we compare the Rooks right like this
this Rooks were off the board but now
uh White still has the pair of Rooks so
white plays King A2 avoiding Queen F5
Queen trade in G7
and um
in in this position because the king is
already so weak there is no reason to
trade Queens even though again like if
we think about the end game the end game
can be very good for white because this
A5 Pawn but now there's a different
element in the position which is this
super weak King so now white can just
simply attack
um attack blocks King and go for
checkmate and if we compare Kings look
how look how comfortable the king is on
a tomb and imagine if white rushed with
their plan of playing G4 and F4 and all
of this and the King was still on the
king side so the King was getting in the
way of things maybe running into some
kind of pins and having to trade Queens
but now the King on A2 is just
completely on the other side of the
board it's like if you look at this
position you would think the king's
camera castled on the other side of the
board and the king is just completely
safe so the queen goes to H4
a Tempo move
should be seven and now Queen back so
here's thread of G1 so now white is
switching sides and playing on the king
side
so the King goes back
and now the Knight comes back
and this is a move that I really like I
really enjoy this kind of Maneuvers when
a piece is on one side of the board it's
doing something and you know it's been
causing some problems for the opponent
and at some point the player realizes
okay now my piece would be doing a
better job on the other side of the
board and then they start this maneuver
like this is something
um
I really enjoy seeing in games
and of course the Knight is headed to E5
and once the Knight
is headed there then it lands there then
would be huge problems so of course
black response with Rook B7
so
stopping this idea because all of a
sudden
there's trouble for um
it's going to be trouble for white light
is actually getting made it here so the
Knight goes back
and now Rook C8
and the problem is trading is not
possible because this is just Queen h8
made
and sorry
if the King goes the other way
um
there's a lot of ways of winning this
position I think F5 is quite convincing
followed with rookie 8.
this Rook is actually I mean okay it's
not trapped but I mean this is kind of a
funny checkmate
so it goes to D7 and then Knight C5 so
now tactically the position is just
falling apart
um which is not surprising whenever one
so it is dominating all their pieces are
in the good squares and you know once
you've done the work of putting all your
pieces on good squares your position is
also good and you know you have some
kind of an advantage it's not surprising
that
tactics will solve they'll be like a
tactical solution to the position
so now 97
huge threat
so Rook C8 loses material of course
because
and then take care
so B3 is played Black is trying to
tactically get out of this but now King
takes
and F5 so the whole point of playing
this move
of this B3 is to phases F5 move because
now D6 is hanging with check
so Rook B6
and now resigns again because the queen
is hanging and this just runs into
Knight
Knight D7 and then taking on B6
so white was just completely dominating
this um game even though like even
though we saw that even in this position
uh black still had defensive resources
it's not like um
unlike in the last game White's
domination wasn't as extensive
black still had the this King G7 mobile
still keeps the game going there's like
um nothing too terrible in Black's
position
but when you do come under this kind of
pressure it's very common to just
collapse and either um not really
foresee how scary your opponent's
threats are or just like kind of miss
something because you're just constantly
under under pressure
and then once we got to this position
we said that once this
King opened up then
white black did manage to bring a
defensive resource to the king but the
problem is white is also bringing more
attackers so once white played Queen H4
here The Rook goes to G1 so now white
has two attackers with this Rooks and
with the queen but black still doesn't
have too many Defenders so now there's
just too many weaknesses in Black's
position so this king is weak and again
in the long term even though it didn't
come to this this A5 Pawn is still a
huge weakness so we said that actually
the king tries to run away but now white
comes from both sides right the screen
is
threatening from this side there's Rook
went to C8 and black just wasn't able to
handle everything
and our final example will be
um
one cow versus levonaronian
it's actually
um
it's a nice example like Taiwan showed
it to me I can't remember why
but he was talking about this and I was
like wow this is so brilliant and this
is
um more of a preventative way
of playing
so I'm going to take a sip of my water
so if we do
um
summary of the position
so white has more space right because of
the spawn structure the pawn on D4
more active than these two pawns we have
opposite color Bishops and opposite
color Bishop positions are very
interesting when it's not a just
opposite color Bishop end game they're
really drawn when we add more pieces on
the board they're really great for
attacking because if I'm a if
why it starts to somehow attack on the
lights worse than black just has no
defense because the dark Square Bishop
cannot defend so if we took this bishop
and put it on B1 there'd be like huge
problems in Black's position because
what is the E7 Bishop going to do
against this
so this structure um you can can have
some long-term
problems for black so if we look at
what's going on so the queen on B4 is
actually quite nicely placed it's
controlling um the dark squares on the
queen side so the queen is not really
free to move this pawns start to hang so
there are some weaknesses in White's
position this G3 pound the C3 Pawn so
it's not like white can do whatever they
want so pushing this E4 Pawn
um something you know an ideal worldwide
maybe wants to do but it just leaves
this D4 Pawn really weak so there's a
dark Square Bishop so we see this Pawn
structure of all entire squares and
light Square bishop and then we see the
spawns on light squares so limiting the
opponent's Bishop so all of this makes a
lot of sense so what we have to look at
is this Pawn structure here
and this H5 Pawn
and we get this kind of structures from
Karo Khan if you're familiar with E4 C6
the 45 Knight C3 that line with Bishop
F5 we get this kind of structure where
White Castles on the opposite side and
because there is a hook in the position
like G4 G5 is very scary so think about
this position again very similar to what
we saw before white has a very clear
idea and block doesn't really have one
because
playing something like C5 leaves them
really vulnerable like okay C5 is not
really possible now but like in the
future trying to do this uh so black has
to think about how to face this
potential of G4 G5 so it's actually not
really possible or advisable
for this King to run to the queen side
so actually it's hard to imagine how
this would even happen with the queen on
before so because but because
blogs pieces are especially the queen
right on this side of the board and the
position is quite locked in with this
Pawn structure so for example the um we
can imagine the King goes to G2 G4 Rook
G1 G5 and then again starting opening up
this queen site and whenever we're
playing on the flank it's a matter of
having control of the center so if the
center doesn't
open if you're playing on a flank like
you're up pushing pawns you have to make
sure the center doesn't open because
that's how your king side collapses
that's how you get in trouble but
because white does have this really nice
grip on the center like this long-term
plan is actually quite scary for black
so in this position King G2 was played
Rook 88
Queen C4 and the trading
um
I don't think this is something
he wanted to do
because
um I think if the bishop goes to B5
maybe something like C5 on the bishop
might get stuck here
but in this position and I remember 11
showing this and he was talking about it
he was like I realized that like this G4
G5 is coming and this is a problematic
thing so he decides to start running
away with the King
the bishop before and he just runs
because he knows something is going to
happen
on the king side and he doesn't want his
King to be there and of course it's
quite risky
for white if the black king runs to the
queen side to start pushing pawns on the
king side because I like he's only
taking risks with his own King
because the other king will be on the
other side of the board I did not mean
to do that
so Rook C7
and he has cleared the path
for his King to run so G4 Queen B6
and now the queen goes King goes to D7
and the King goes to C8
so in this position they just kind of
shuffled back and forth because I think
one how I realized that
this whole expedition of playing Rook
Chivan and rook and pawn to G5 is just
too risky because at some point black
will be able to play C5 and the C file
will open and like the king will just
become too vulnerable so they just
played Bishop C4 and they just
shuffled back and forth
and the game ended in a drum
but um
so like the examples that we've seen is
the king like we saw how the Kings
there's marches and dominates the word
but I think this is such a nice example
of the like foreseeing the danger and
for so far from far away too and just
running to the other side of the board
yeah
in which position
is it possible
somehow
leave the queen on C2 to prevent the
game lock like it doesn't look like
Black's gonna do anything in the
meantime
um
uh so like in this position instead of
that let's say if you go
G4
in this position immediately I think I
might be able to play like C5 even
um
but okay like even if I go here maybe my
moves are not ideal like I put a bishop
on F6
yeah now if
okay but okay you can come back I don't
think this is such a huge deal
okay but if you come back here and then
like I'm able to play this this actually
will become problematic yeah I mean the
thing about this position like um G4 G5
is like the only idea for white to do
some kind of a breakthrough so it either
works or it doesn't
and like to do it when your own King is
there like it's um and the king is not
there it's kind of risky like in this
position
I think the way they would do it he
would go like G4 maybe King H3 and then
Rook G1 and then play G5 something like
this
try to clean it off first
real life
uh yeah even with the Queen's off though
like the only it's just going to be
pressure on Black's position
I mean again you're playing kind of you
know you're just defending against your
opponent's plan and you don't really
have a plan of your own
right but like I mean I like this is one
of like I think like obviously if your
opponent has a very clear threat right
I'm going to be like um sacrificing
something or doubling my Rooks and
checkmating it's like a very easy idea
to see and to stop but like to foresee
this like G4 G5 and you're like oh this
is going to be annoying and this is not
something I want to deal with and to use
a King march as a preventative method I
thought it was just like such a unique
example of just running away from all
the problems in the position and then
all of a sudden your king is just other
side of the world and your king is the
one that's fine and now G5 is just not
even something you ever have to worry
about because just carry so many risks
for black
or white not for black
okay this was it for me
um this was you know we had five
examples of King marches actually at
some point I was just searching I was
also read through I really like this
Yasser book he co-wrote it I forgot with
who but he has like they have like
different chapters of like
in the end game when you're on the
winning side when you're on the losing
side and then as at some point like
Levon showed me this position and um
like I I started making a database of
King runs and like I don't know how I
even came across from them I also had
like one firusha game where the king
just runs on the opposite side of the
board just like takes all of the
opponent's pawns there's also one very
famous One by David Navarro I think or
do the I don't think he's like a middle
game and then or like at least a
queenless end game and the king is just
in some crazy line just runs and doesn't
get mated somehow
but yeah this is um a topic I actually
enjoy because I think it's such an
enjoyable
concept and you know if you get to do
this in the game just feels really good
the chances that I've had in my games
I've missed them unfortunately but um I
think a nice thing to keep in mind oh I
clicked on something
all right so that was it for me today
um